to the next item which is the youth
council
so we've got a couple of members who've
come along this afternoon if you'd like
to pop up into the graham norton not
read chairs
you're quite safe welcome along
last meeting of the youth council was on
wednesday afternoon last week
but since then i think it was on on
saturday you had
the um your event next door
do you want to go through what was what
was involved and how that worked out
uh kyoto i'm evening from the unders
youth council and i go to south and
girls high school
um um i'm nazia from overs youth council
and i also go to south and girls high
school
so um yeah um last saturday um 10th of
july
the united nation came down
[Music]
u.n youth came down and held a six-hour
regional hui with 20 young people from
invercargill and southland area
and um while i'm at it i would also like
to thank councillor um sober
for coming along to the event as well
and
we started the day getting to know each
other and hearing
from our guest speaker who were talking
about the difficulties
getting youth engagement in politics
um short after we were learning about
the tikanga mori protocols
and we thought like how it would be good
to
introduce that to the youth council as
well
in the second part of the day we had um
rugby group time
where we discussed national issues
and coming up with solutions for those
and there was one
issue that stuck out to me which was the
topic of homelessness
which if i may um raise a question i
remember about a couple years ago
um with the there was a project with
kiwibuild
announced by the government to build 40
houses in invercargill
and i was just wondering how that
project is coming along since i haven't
heard much about it since
it would be fair to say that kiwibuild
wasn't a raging success so far
elsewhere in the country but i think
there are still plans to to look for
opportunities there have been
uh some smaller developments that have
gone ahead but certainly not at the
the rates that are needed to deal with
homelessness so i i think counselor
sophie you may well know that the
package still sits on the table
and they're looking for the
opportunities the number is still
similar
yeah yeah thank you thanks for your
question
um it was good to hear other people's
perspectives from other schools
um around southland it was good to see
conflicts and debate
and not everyone just agreeing with each
other we had um sit morals as a group
like not lying respecting others views
and making it a safe space to share
we had teresa the president of united
nations youth
who was engaging in fun we got a
follow-up email the next day which um
had event details and contact details of
the speakers and web links to
follow up on we had marlon from
elections as
our guest speaker who zoomed in from
christchurch he was the deputy head boy
at his former school and involved in the
pegasus health board
one thing we were surprised it was the
age of youth that the electoral
commission
uh asked to engage with was 18 to 29.
there wasn't much information about how
we can make it different as a minor in
democracy
we would also like to thank you for the
catering and we'd like to thank the
youth council leadership committee and
the eu in youth for putting this day
together
thank you um councillors it's open
over here for questions counselor sopa
thank you mr chair um i don't have a
question i do just want to say i
i went along as an interested observer
and i just wanted to comment that i was
very impressed at the time i was at this
meeting with the maturity
and the breadth of issues that the young
people were discussing
the fact that you were looking locally
nationwide and internationally and what
you were raising as
issues that were worthy of discussion
and the fact that you were prepared to
discuss in quite some depth and that you
were having very
mature discussions between the young
people who are in the room
it gave me a lot of confidence about the
safety
we can feel about the future of our
democracy if we've got young people
prepared to put in that time
and energy on a saturday when you could
have been doing many other things
to be in a room discussing very
important issues
so very complimentary of
what what happened that day having been
through that process
and and discussing and debating and and
that atmosphere
how do you expect it might change the
way that you engage
with the youth council
um i think that there was like this more
realization of all the issues
now that we had that day and i think
that it opens for more discussion
in youth council with those issues i
guess my question is does it give you
confidence
to to to raise your voice and and
champion the people
definitely should feel strongly yes
definitely yes
you wish so chair i think one of the key
issues you'll face as young people in
the city is getting a home
and i know it sounds a simple
project but just
countless um
ministers of the parliament and
people from all walks of life you'd
think we'd be able to solve this problem
it what what was some of the thoughts
around that
i'm sorry can you repeat you're looking
at ways of becoming home buyers
or other initiatives like home
builders or sweat equity i think it's
called
if the answer was no that's fine
have a ponder of it and and if we come
up with an answer through youth council
we can take it back to its worship
yeah cool any other questions counselors
counselor crack it you after uh happy to
move the recommendation
indeed secondary to second thank you
councillor sopra i'll put that all in
favor
all right against carried thank you very
much for your time on saturday and and
going along
to to be a part of the event and for
taking time out and you know having to
leave school early to get along here and
present to us this afternoon thank you
very much
thank you school school school holidays
i still thank you you'll be doing
anything or no you can
counsellors that brings us on to the
minutes of performance policy and
partnerships from tuesday the 8th of
june does somebody want to move they're
trying correct
councillor sopa seconded councillor
amundsen
any matters arising
if not i'll put the motion all in favor
aye
against carried
we've got the minutes of the
extraordinary uh meeting
on june 30th councillor abbott seconded
councillor bottinger any matters arising
if not i put the motion all in favor aye
against
carried
right potential submissions on the
legislation
relating to environmental reforms which
kind of follows on from
what we were hinting at with mr moyer
before
welcome along liz do you want to take us
through the paper
kiara um my report is really a heads up
um
as you may be aware there's a reform um
proposed by the
current government to wipe out what we
have now in the resource management act
and replace it with three other pieces
of legislation
the process involved in bringing this
piece of legislation these other three
pieces of legislation
into into effect is going to be quite
fast
and it's not going to give us a lot of
time or opportunity to have input into
it
in 2020 there was a randison report
released which gave a critique of the
resource management
system as it is now and gave some ideas
going forward
and the government is taking that report
as a as
pretty much the consultation or the
background to the new piece of
legislation coming forward
this report um has been brought to you
just to
advise you that there is this reform
going ahead and that there is a
submission process
that council may want to to be involved
in
however due to the really tight time
frames and giving that
those submission processes there may not
be an opportunity for us to workshop or
bring it to council for
for a resolution or discussion um and so
we are hoping to to make a submission
on behalf of icc um we've got but the
most recent piece of legislation
that's come out to us in terms of an
exposure draft
is the natural and built environment act
we've got until the start of august to
make a submission on that so we've only
got two more weeks
to submit just to let you know staff are
working with
the other southern councils um in this
space
and as we're also working with the
councils from around otago as well
um so today this morning we had a
two-hour zoom meeting with the otago
south and
regional managers um to see if there are
any ways that we can
can accumulate work together and come up
with a submission that covers both
that doesn't necessarily mean that we
wouldn't put our own submission and we
didn't
agree with what the other councils
wanted to see
thanks liz and it's good to hear that
there's a regional approach being
being taken um i guess i i can
appreciate that the short turnaround
means that
you're looking for for some license to
be able to
to be nimble but i think because we're
looking at doing that uh
collaboratively with the other councils
i take a bit of confidence in that
counselors it's open for questions or
comments councillor pottinger
thank you chair um liz can you just give
us
just a couple of quick sentences the
guts of what the natural
and built environments build sort of
contains that
that would worry us right
so currently in new zealand we've got
over over 100
um plans for the regional level and a
district council level
um the new legislation would like to
accumulate all of those um
plans so the regional plans and the
district plans down into one plan per
region so there would be 14 plans
so before that can be
created the natural built environment
sector is proposing that there'll be a
national planning framework so it
at a central government high level state
they will guide us as to what the
outcomes are that we should have in our
district plans um there will be another
piece of legislation which is a
strategic planning act
which will come out at the same time as
the natural
environment act and that will ask us to
have a regional spatial plan
um and from that we will build that into
a
natural and built environment plan which
is essentially what a
what a district plan is and what the
regional plans are
thank you councillor cracker thank you
councilman
um what's the um implementation of
regional plans
uh and did we stand to lose any local
autonomy on how we allocate resources
yes um so the whole planning system will
be
completely changed from what we know it
is now um
and there will be committees that will
be sit outside
the council so each local authority will
have
one person nominated to sit on that
committee who will make the policy
um as well as the tango defender of the
region
so um just for argument's sake if we
were to
decide um that we want expansion in a
particular area of the city
it would be not only up to us but our
regional
counterparts to agree that that is
actually
of benefit to the city i see that as a
risk because how is that
up to the southern district council or
to decide what we
do with our city boundaries
so essentially at the um regional
spatial plan
stage that would be the time that we
would have input into
where our growth areas or um maybe
debates will happen then in terms of
where industrial development should be
and
all of those sorts of things so um
potentially fraught
um quite a different approach to what we
have now
works two ways though i'm sure that
rural counterparts are probably feeling
similarly nervous
councilor soper then councillor arnold
thanks mr chair um
i'm certainly very supportive of putting
in
the submission and where possible making
it a regional view
although there's obviously some points
where there might be
slightly different views in the region
but i do just want to make it clear this
is an exposure draft
which means the legislation hasn't yet
been formally
introduced into parliament when it is
introduced there will be a normal select
committee process
which includes the calling of
submissions so i just for
for the sake of the public i just wanted
to make it very clear
this is not the only chance we will have
to
put forward the council's views on this
particular issue yeah that's right um at
the moment the exposure draft is only a
high level there are a whole lot of
place
keepers within the document that we've
got yet
um that we don't have detail on that
will come they were hoping early next
year we will have
the bill that will go to um go for for
further
formal submission process so through you
mr chair
i just wanted to emphasize that this is
our opportunity
to make our submission contribute to the
bill
being a well-written bill
councillor arnold um
um being that we won't have a time
coming off shop or
um have any views at all on to
as to what performing the submissions
will take do you have any idea rough
idea
what things that you'll be looking to
add into the submissions because
obviously the submission will be
to give them things that we would like
as a region
down the airway so if you have any ideas
could you elaborate if there's anything
you could sort of just tell us what
you're thinking of we haven't really
formulated a view as of yet and we've
only really been given it a couple of
weeks ago to sit down and work out the
detail
um discussions at this morning with the
regional
level was just making sure the nuts and
bolts that the wording is consistent
through
um it talks about limit setting outcome
setting
um and just making sure that the process
actually works
um there's some matters that can be
dealt with through the national planning
framework
and some matters that aren't required to
be in the national planning framework
and we need to make sure
that things like high-value soils
and the competing interests with that
and
the demands for urban growth are dealt
with
appropriately so it's it's really i
haven't
we haven't formulated a specific level
yet but um
we just want to make sure that the built
environment
is given as much input as the natural
environment
um at the moment it seems to be quite
focused on
air and water and the natural world
if i may um i think it's like it's
probably fair to say that
uh the key message in our submission
will be there's insufficient detail
in which to submit right
wouldn't be the first time what time
have made that sort of submission lately
but
any other questions counsellors
still recommendations here the reports
received and endorsed the approach the
council officers be able to prepare in
larger submissions i'm happy to move
that is there a secondary
put that all in favor against caring
michael come on up
update on earthquake prone buildings
good afternoon um i'll briefly summarize
the work to date before taking any
questions if you
if you'd like now following an amendment
to the building act in 2017
the council here said about public
consultation process in order to
identify priority
priority building areas within our
district these were areas of sufficient
vehicular
or pedestrian traffic or of strategic
importance
this was completed in 2018 and resulted
in the priority areas shown at the
of your the rear of your report being
identified
we then carried out inspections on 420
buildings in that area
and following that 211 buildings were
identified as potentially earthquake
prone
through 2018 and 2019 owners were then
written to requesting
they provide engineering assessments
within 12 months
due to the covert lockdown last year the
one-off extension of 12 months was
provided to these owners
we're now at the end of this extension
period and we've moved into reviewing
engineering assessments and making
decisions on whether buildings are
earthquake prone
the numbers in the summary table at the
end of the report show that
for the year to date we've issued 93
earthquake plane building notices
there are two types of notices i'll get
jonathan to
to hold these up so the
one on the left there they aren't with
the orange border that's for buildings
with a zero to 20
rating it's got the distinct orange
border around it
the other one we put out is for
buildings between 20 and 34
so it's just plain black and white all
over
we're going to be seeing these in the
city going forward building owners are
required to fix these in prominent
locations on the front of their building
some buildings require multiple multiple
signage with their multiple entry points
the intent behind these is that building
building users
know what they walk into before they go
in
in addition to that the buildings are
also identified in the mb online
earthquake prime building register
now we're receiving calls from building
owners and likewise tenants who've
suddenly realized they're in an
earthquake prime building it's fair to
say
it's not being well received
unfortunately there's little
to do little way around this with it
being a legislative requirement
put on us by central government the
remaining priority buildings
relate to emergency use medical centres
and education buildings
they're being worked on separately with
relevant agencies or ministries
once we've finished the priority
buildings our attention then switches to
the non-priority buildings around the
city
there looks to be approximately 2 000
properties which we have to investigate
going forward thank you very much
thanks for the good news michael
councillor partner
thank you cheer um right just uh i'm
going to pick
a random earthquake prone building out
of the blue
say the old hotel in front of the bluff
oyster
um what's the future with that of the
people being
served an earthquake notice so the
options that
i mean it's a tough one
it is a tough one there seems to be a
common theme i'm hearing
with other buildings similar of similar
age
from the day they're issued the
earthquake builder notice for those
priority buildings with gall street
bluffers
a priority area they've got 12 and a
half years
to seismically upgrade their building
or knock it down we'll knock it down i'm
not sure the heritage issues with that
one rick what happens with the heritage
then when you're in a
stalemate um we haven't got to that
point yet
i can probably speak to that a little
bit more um you're just a clarification
you're specifically talking about the
club hotel
it's the yeah the one and um yes so uh
it's yet to be determined how that will
actually fall out the legislation was
changed in 2017.
um we're in the early stages of the
implementation
um under the rma there is no um
our absolute requirement for stewardship
on a building to the point that it has
to be retained
beyond all date so that has to be taken
into account
and with that specific building we are
actually in discussion with the owners
about what the next steps will be for
them
okay and those discussions would be
available to people in the same position
yeah exactly thank you just just further
today if they are a heritage one
category one or two to new zealand
building they can apply for a 10-year
extension to the 12 and a half year
period
they can only do that after they've
received the notice
can they do their ongoing or is it just
a one-off it's a one-off one
councillor keith yeah going through the
um
priority buildings um and heritage
buildings
the next cab off the rank were
council-owned buildings
if they've all been inspected as the
stage the ones that reside in the
priority area
yes they've been part of this and have
the reports been received back to
council
on all them
the report's been come from your
division back to council
ah i'm not aware of that name that'll be
with paul horner
we've received the reports in line with
the time frame certainly
the building services department have
received the vote are you asking if
they've come to council
yeah through the ceo or the mayor in his
office
we can follow up for you and if that's
not the case we can certainly enjoy it
i will have gone to the office of the ce
if there was
a resounding issue um but we
will follow up and just check on that
for you
there's a lot of interest out there with
the museum
that once obviously closed i know it is
but there's
a lot of people still asking uh has the
report been
inspections been done and completed and
reports received so
i'm just asking that question on behalf
of the number of ratepayers right
you didn't specify the museum
you asked about council buildings
which of course the museum is now but we
had a
report an intrusive report done and
council's in possession of it
was there something else you were after
well i just went up onto the
an update councillor clark yeah just as
a
follow-on from that um it might be able
to give me some help with this
i don't understand why the museum is
actually a priority area
when you look at the clas class one
criteria that's in the
thing it talks about high traffic and
and the ability of um
emergency services to use the roads and
and it seems odd on the map that we've
put a little pink
boundary around the museum yet it sits
on a road that has little
or no traffic and only minimal foot
traffic at any one point of time
so i was interested in why that's class
one because it was class two
or not priority um the time frames the
result would be twenty five years not
twelve and a half
the other issue is whether we've
actually done that yet given that um
it's in the
thing i think that's what my colleague
council was asking about
i thought it was interesting with the uh
with the analogy of the club hotel
in uh bluff bluff community have tried
already all the trust that owns it has
tried already to get a consent to uh
to flatten the building um the response
from the heritage people was that they
were okay with that
and they were declined on the grounds
that they hadn't made an economic case
for
expanding the oyster vessel um so
leading on from council ponder saying i
thought that was interesting as well
that
is that do we have a does an owner like
that have
a mandate now that they've been
designated to push for a
consent if it's a risk so interested in
both issues
one the museum and one about the club
hotel sure
all i can say on the museum so that was
put out for public consultation and then
adopted by council in 2018 was a council
decision to include the museum
sure um i might get jonathan to comment
on the resource consent side
uh all i can really say is that we're
still stepping through it with the
building owners
the earthquake pro legislation you're
talking about 12 and a half years and
there's
there's a difference between immediately
dangerous and then an earthquake growing
so
we need to bear in mind as well yep just
just going back to the
museum again then um so
while we might have consulted about the
priority areas
the egg does have the definition of
class 1 and class 2.
that's my understanding and so if we've
got that wrong if we designated priority
or the community consultation is
designated in such a way that it's
priority or class 1 when in fact the act
determines it somewhere else then surely
the act would apply wouldn't it
um it's not so much class one or two
that's that's more related to the
heritage the
the discussion with the council is if
it's sufficient vehicular or pedestrian
traffic i'm sure we can only assume that
council considers enough people at the
museum to warrant of being a risk
thank you councillor cricket thank you
councillor i just wanted to
um give a little bit of context to
why council had included the museum and
you'll also notice on that map there
that there's the
water tower and the water utilities
included in that as well is that this
council
in that time last term wanted to lead by
example and make sure that if we were
uh having those zonings where we were
ensuring that we were going to be
you know issuing earthquake prone
notices that council wanted to be
leading from the front and ensure that
we
too were putting those notices on our
buildings and making sure that we were
holding ourselves accountable to the
legislation so
that's why they were included we didn't
want to be seen to be you know
one standard for the public and another
standard for
ourselves i hope that gives you a bit of
context on that
counselor thanks mr chair i just want to
concur
exactly with councillor councillor um
crackit's
memory of the decision there it was very
much to do with
us being seen is actually leading by
example and
not um being open to accusations that we
had deliberately
favored our own buildings when we were
drawing a line
around a large part of the inner city
thank you and further questions or
comments
not the report is intended as an update
and thank you very much for that there
are three recommendations of somebody
wants to move you're right counselor
have you torn something i thought it
stopped
rip the bandage off yes absolutely thank
you for that i'll move secondary
edmondson rather than jack the ripper
i'll put that all in favor against
carrie thank you very much for that
thank you
thanks councillors that brings us to uh
mr morris's report
on the manafenoua appointed roles
um just before we go into this i will
go around each of the councillors um to
canvas your opinions on it but i'm going
to um
make use of standing orders so that's
really the speak
once so when you've got an opinion you
want to share you have one opportunity
to do it
you can ask additional questions of
clarification
um but those are legitimate questions
not cleverly
couched comments if you're all
comfortable with that
mr morris thank you yeah thank you
tennis
councillors good afternoon um chair your
worship
counsellors this is the manifesto report
before i go through
my report there are just
a handful of small changes i need to
make to the recommendations
just changing one word
uh and adding a new number five and
renumbering current number five to
number six
this is just uh for clarity uh
so the first change is in 2.1
i've currently got a points i would like
to change that to create
yeah so establish
no let's go for establish i think that
was that's a better word
um and then so this is 2.1 in my
recommendations
and then insert in a new number five
which is to resolve to appoint the
persons to the roles
on 24 august 2021 which is the next
council meeting
at the first council meeting in august
sorry could you resolve to appoint the
persons
to the roles
on 24 august
2021
and then number five becomes number six
to the aim with that was just to provide
that clarity that council was still yet
to formally appoint the persons into the
roles
um rather than at not being as
specific as it could have been so i do
apologize for that
right so without further ado into my
report
you'll recall on the 11th of may uh it
was determined not to proceed with a
maori award for
the city at the october 2022 elections
at that time following feedback from
both manufa
and the wider community a report was
called for on
the establishment of roles for
manafenoua
this is that report and you'll notice
obviously from the recommendations that
the staff recommendation is that these
roles are
created and are
established as to be operative from
september
2021 so the appointments will need to be
made on 20
for august which is the council meeting
before september
the roles would be for one person each
from both of the runaka who
are in our city district so wai hopai
and arawa
and i will notice a cave and a note that
dunedin city council recently adopted a
similar measure
for their manufenua seats last month
as part of our ongoing obligation to all
of maori i am recommending that we also
engage with matawaka
to ensure that their voices continue to
be heard
i notice a number of councils have uh
arrangements between mana work with
manifenua and matawaka to ensure that
there is an adequate representation of
all mighty voices
and this is the start of that process
with matawaka
i think it is an important step to take
to engage appropriately with
all of maori but importantly we need
to engage firstly with amanafenua
um and
there is the uh point in there that
it is recommended that these roles be
renumerated by way of an honorarium
that has not yet been the level of that
has not yet been determined the reason
for that is we need to work with
manufenua to establish the scope of the
roles which
if they are established today we will
have an idea
and that can come back by way of a
report to the cheers
committee once their work has been
finalized
so i'm aware that there will be a number
of questions that want to be asked so i
don't intend to take any more time going
through my report
but i am as always happy to answer
questions thanks michael can i just ask
a question of clarification around
process whilst we're receiving the
report
the recommendations from this meeting
today go forward to
full council for adoption only for
council can resolve to
appoint roles to the committees thank
you
okay councillors if we start with
questions first and then we'll
we'll get into uh expression of opinion
shortly after councillor abbott then
councillor clark michael i just wondered
why it was going back to the chairman's
committee about the remuneration and not
coming back to this committee
uh at the moment my view is the chairs
committee is an appropriate place
because
that's where the uh chairs will be it's
a
useful venue that's my recommendation
happy to have um council resolve that it
comes back to full council to determine
um this committee
yeah i'm comfortable by the way
thanks councillor clark yeah through
eugen um
i'd like to move an amendment to the
cluster on
on recommendations too we haven't got
anything for you to amend yet
i'm just trying to deal with questions
at the moment
but by amend no one has put the
recommendations
so therefore it is impossible to amend
can we just deal with questions first
and then we'll we'll get to the
recommendations
do you have some some questions what do
you want to hold on
i've got a series on if you want to work
right that's fine
well the floor is yours thank you
michael um
just some uh issues around the report
that aren't clear to me
um you've said there that in
recommendation four
that we've yet to adopt that we would
consult with mata waka
and recommendation four on the role of
marry within the local government act
um how do you perceive that we'll do
that with the two
appointed roles being manufenua only
so the imported roles are for manafenoua
because they are who
the treaty relationship is with mata
waka
are included and they all have maori
framework within the local government
act
which is why it's important to also
engage with them to make sure that they
have an appropriate mechanism to engage
with
council however when we consider the
treaty
of waitangi and its obligations that is
with the manifenoa of
this land which is the urunaka of
naitahu
so you're suggesting that that mata
waka's voice will need to be through
manufa
and away yeah yes okay that's fine not
exclusively
sure um i noticed that we you've
recommended here that we have two
nanga appointees one from each one from
our
one from wahoo pai um
i don't understand why uh this isn't
this representation isn't a
tribal one so we're naidah representer
present us with a representative as
opposed to having one per minute because
if you consider the
um if you consider ngati peroan and the
gisborne
district council they've got 71 rights
now would never be suggested you have 71
people on the committee
so i don't know why we have two and we
actually should only in my view have one
so i'd like some understanding about why
we've landed with two as opposed to one
we've gone with two on this case because
we have two
the two who are both representing
different areas
they have different interests sometimes
they could be competing interests
each council is free to make its own
decision on how it
best involves manafenoua
i acknowledge your point that in areas
in the north island i come from one
number two there are many mirai
in the manawatu including different ewe
surrounding
and uh for example
but in this council we have turonaka who
both sit within our district boundaries
they are able to both be represented at
this council table they both have a
voice that needs to
be heard
if the runaka felt they could be
represented by one person
they would tell us and we would promote
that on their behalf
of course the council can determine to
have
one representative uh that is an option
available to the council but the staff
recommendation is that we have tarunanga
like dunedin city it seems logical to
involve both of them
within decisions in these committees
yeah i could i could understand that
but um one of the recommendations in
recommendation two
is that we're offering uh our mirai
a representative on the bluff community
board so that would seem to me that
the signal their their voice is already
being heard through that mechanism
why do they then get another seat or
another voice
at a committee level as well given that
the club
bluff community board reports back to us
so the bluff community board is only an
advisory role it's not able to be a
voting role
uh and for that reason they
have felt that that need to be at the
committee table where their votes will
count uh the bluff community board
has a limited number of delegations
compared to both of these committees and
it's important to have
a district that's represented both of
its furunaka
uh not excluding bluff or the arawa
deunake boundaries um
just a couple of more questions um i've
heard today that you say that um dunedin
have
adopted a uh two representatives
um do you know what honorariums are
being paid to those people
that hasn't been determined yet for my
understanding but we will be in contact
with dunedin city to
engage with them on what they are doing
in your view without preempting
what council may decide is it reasonable
to accept that
if we wanted an eary voice on our
committees they'd be paid the same as a
councillor
oh um i don't have a personal view on
what they could be
paid yep that's fine and the very last
issue for me i guess is the one of um
our significant engagement policy would
seem to me reading that policy
that this is a significant shift in our
democracy
to include these ewe appointees
i can't see the rationale in the paper
where you say
when you're going to say there is no
need to consult with the public on this
matter
so the rationale behind that was that
this
follows on from the maori ward
discussion that we had
consulted as part of the maori ward
discussion while i acknowledge
immediately that maori ward and
receipts are different issues they were
linked
sufficiently for that level of
engagement that we felt comfortable not
to proceed to full public engagement
again that is the decision that if this
council chooses to
do public engagement uh
then that will be the resolution and we
will i will work with rhiannon and her
team to ensure that public engagement
takes place and it is heard so to
let me just test that um line of logic
just a little bit
um so at the time we went to
consultation over the mary ward
did the public or were the public
advised that a consequence of that
consultation may be that subsequently
we might install uh two appointed roles
without public consultation because it
seems to me we only went to the public
on the mary ward issue
so they were linked at the time of the
discussions with the public
that the maori award was discussed
uh that when we were talking with
the public that there were other options
to ensure
maori voices at council being the
manifest seats
but i acknowledge your point that at the
time we went to consultation it was on
the maori award question it was
not specifically on the monofinal roles
but they were linked sufficiently for it
to be considered that it was appropriate
to be able to proceed without full and
further public consultation on this
issue
one final question and that that's the
membership of uh
on committees for people who are not
elected
by way of the norm election process do
the people that
are committed to these appointments are
they covered by the local government act
so fragments are they subject to codes
of conduct
the provisions of public exclusive
meetings police screening
as they are appointed to this committee
and the answer was yes okay thank you
do i have you thank you further
questions
um mine wasn't really a question it was
a comment to support what michael was
saying
i could make the same thing and that i
heard the consultation
and the three venues that i was at touch
on the matawaka seats
and if you know seats
other questions at this point before we
do a round table
right if there are none uh then we first
need
something to debate so i'm going to
move the two recommendations as amended
so that's recommendation one received
the
report and recommendation to recommend
the council established two roles one
for each ranaka on the performance
policy and partnerships committee
and the infrastructural services
committee with full voting rights
uh offices offers an advisory role to
the bluff community board for tirurai
or resolves to consult with takata
fenuwa
on persons to be appointed to the roles
and implementation issues
resolves to consult with matawaka on the
creation of manafenuwa appointed roles
and the role of almighty within the
local government at 2002
framework resolve to appoint the persons
to the roles on 24
august 2021 resolved to commence the
roles from
september 2021. there's epitome
mr chair thank you it now opens it
for discussion counselor clark sure
i'd like to move a uh amendment to the
um clustering two one through two six
and replace it with that this paper
should be left on the table without any
decisions
for the incoming council on october 2022
to consider an act upon
so that is a proposed amendment to uh
recommendation too sure is there a
second tip for that clarify
you're saying leave it till the next
term
that is what i heard concrete like say
yes
i'll read it again if it helps members
i'm sorry this paper be left on the
table
without any decisions for the incoming
council in october
2022 which is the next election to
consider
and act upon
so that's proposed amendment that needs
a secondary
the lack of a second day of the
amendment lapses which brings us back to
councillor kit
yes i've seen that
very well there's nothing like just
after the gate shuts
however i'll not deny you the
opportunity
so on the amendment council councillor
clark you have the
right to speak uh thank you chad this
recommendation
aligns with option three that's in the
paper that's been presented to us today
which gave us an option to consider an
information
implementation date at the next election
my recommendation goes further than that
and suggests that we shouldn't make a
decision today that we should wait and
consider other things
matters that are before us that we
haven't considered so
support for the recommendation that i've
just put is that there are a raft of
issues within the paper that need
further analysis
beyond that the approval of manufacturer
roles
does in my view not aligned with hikira
the paper being developed or has been
developed by the government
the direction of naitahu leadership in
recent times
the two 2010 human rights commission
report
nor the 2021 local government reform
panel mandate
as i said previously further given that
this approval
has a significance to our committee is
unacceptable to me
that we do not open the discussion for
public consultation
in relation to heep plan that's a recent
there's been recent national debate over
this plan which was commissioned by the
labour government
the plan is a 20-year plan to afford
rangatiratanga
a framework to the tribes i understand
that 38-page report has not yet been
formally adopted by
cabinet but there is no doubt that the
recent government activity
has already embedded the core principles
of co-design
co-governance self-determination of all
services
that in the future will impact on ewe
rangatiratanga and the plan is very much
about ewe having ownership
self-determination co-governance and
control of wide range of crown
activities that impact on ewe
i see this as a very positive and
important development
the co-design and co-governance
principle is evidenced by dia
suggesting to naitahu that equal
stakeholder group that we now have in
the three waters
group that we've been considering so the
two stakeholder groups with equal say
are the 28 councils on one side and
naitahu
on the other you can also see
similar criteria being embedded in
recent developments around the regional
strategic
partnership fund which is a 200 million
dollar fund that follows the
provincial growth fund and also the
recent police rock program which is to
build resilience around organized crime
the human rights commission report that
came out in 2010 had
some interesting implications for the
government the report reflected on maori
representation and local government
it stated the local government was very
inconsistent and
there was a reluctance to address these
issues including from central government
one of the key recommendations back 11
years ago was there needed to be further
national
discussion on improved provisions for
maori representation
prior to he he was just recently come to
the fore
i'm not aware of any national discussion
around this issue
on the issue of direction of naitah
leadership i think there are
several points to consider naitahu
leadership in christchurch was very
clear recently
that he is coming and will determine
a different approach to the well-being
to their well-being
their rangatiratanga their control of
their own futures
to quote timari poe who was at the
meeting with mares
this is coming you need to suck it up it
is going to wash over all of you
and while that was intimidating for some
people i thought it was a good statement
by the tribe
that the old status quo way of dealing
with things was no longer
fit for purpose the guiding principles
of the hippopota
now overarch the local government reform
process
interesting to note that um what we're
attempting to do is going in the
opposite direction from what naitahi
leadership
are wanting to go and i'll deserve that
in two areas
the southam mural forum which is a high
level
significant leadership forum in southam
that involves the four mayors
recently offered naitaahu one position
for each runanga
with voting rights on our structure so
that gave
four more votes back into a forum that
only had them
four mayors and four deputy mayors naita
who rejected that offer
and on the issue of the electoral maori
awards naito had the chance for a maori
ward at the next elections
and turned that down as well so both
these rejections for
in my view um reflect for me that
naitah is no longer seeking to be a
minority role on any group
and to me that would include this
council under partnership and
consultation principles of the past
because those status quo things have not
delivered
an increased well-being for the tribe
and its members they are now seeking
rangatira retirement principles
as defined in the 1998 naitari
settlement act by way of co-design and
co-governance
and a bicultural approach that avoids
separatism
having said that under there is
considerable separatism
in the outcomes of the 2020 sorry of the
20-year iperia plan
and so um from my perspective the draft
report and final reports that are coming
from the local government
reform panel will be available for us at
the 2022 election
it would seem to be appropriate to wait
to identify what local government will
look like
we may not be here post the next
elections we could be in
a combined council with other councils
and what direction central government
is giving to maori representation rather
than embedding a manafenoua role now
only to possibly change it in late 2022
or in 2023 without knowing what central
government or naita
wish from this he pueri per plan
and what the local government reform
will guide us on
is my view it's inappropriate to approve
these monophenol roles
until we know what is expected of us and
other councils
thank you thank you councillor clark
just so
councillors are clear what we are
speaking on now is councillor clark's
proposed amendment
that the item sit on the table until the
next trianium
other speakers for or against councillor
sopa
and in his worship
thank you mr chair and speaking against
the amendment i want to start by saying
people can find a million reasons
for putting off or delaying to tomorrow
what should be done today look at some
of the issues through history which came
down to the same sort of arguments
councillor clark has just been
presenting
the arguments against the abolition of
slavery
some of those arguments came down to
slaves are children who won't be able to
manage by themselves so let's leave it
for another century or two
look at the arguments against the
extension of both of the vote
to woman which came down largely to
women do not have the intelligence to
handle the vote let's leave it for
another generation or two until they are
educated
until men have delivered them the
ability to reason to the extent that
they can exercise a vote responsibly
let's bring it to the modern setting
1981
arguments against the
protests at the spring box tour which
came down largely to let's keep
politics out of sport and let's have
white teams because we've always had
them and we we want to have a rugby game
2007 the argument that it was not the
right time
to repeal section 59 of the crimes act
and to address the issue of family
violence
in this nation
a lot of those issues come down to
arguments from people who
are talking from the view of fear of
change
a desire to have the state safe status
quo that they have
already had the safe and unchanging
status quo that they have had for all
their lives and which they would like to
continue
but sometimes just sometimes
history catches up with you
and it becomes the right time to do the
right thing
the proposal from councillor clark to
amend
comes down to a misrepresentation of hai
puapua
i am not going to do a great deal of
speaking on that because i think that
misrepresentation can be researched by
anyone
it is not accepted government policy it
was a discussion paper
it also comes down to a
misrepresentation of the views of
naitahu leadership
and i would like to point out that no
one at this table can speak for the
naitahu leadership
as i said in speaking against this
amendment
sometimes history catches up with us
it's time the right time to do the right
thing
this for me is one of those times
it's time that we actually acknowledge
that we are a bicultural nation
nothing that counselor clark has put
forward and speaking to his amendment
seem to me to acknowledge that
we are a bicultural nation whose
indigenous peoples
were promised unique rights
through a treaty partnership and we
haven't
got there yet this council has the
chance today
with the substantive motions to actually
start that delivery
to actually say that we do wish
our cultural partners to be at the same
table
in a meaningful way i'm not going to
delay any further but i do want to
finish with this
mater matukuru
with your food basket and my food basket
people will thrive i will be voting
against this amendment i will be voting
for council to take the brave step
that it is time and the right time
to deliver partnership not just
the occasional poultry or the occasional
ability to sing a wyatta but an
actual commitment to the partnership
that will take this nation and our
peoples forward
thank you you worship
yes well i find myself in an unusual
situation
counsellor that's so bad because i agree
with
what you're saying i feel the time
that we've put off issues and just
kicked for touches the colloquial
version of it just can't go on
we've got to at some stage
face up to our obligations that our
colonial powers made with the queen
or the crown and there's been
countless books now and literature
claudia orange was a
classic case that many writers
and artists have turned towards looking
at that
vital part of our community
the uh situation
of trying to lock out
some of the tangata fenua is not
um an option to my mind
we've got to face up to this
and we've got to do it as quickly as we
can
and people have adjusted we've
i marched against the treaty of waitangi
saying it was a fraud
uh but it was um
oh sorry there's some someone bungee
jumping outside the window
as long as they come back up yes that's
what i thought
um see
uh it isn't an unusual issue
i went to matariki over the weekend
two weekends ago and
it was packed and people loved the
thought that we got involved in actually
being part of an event that celebrates
the relationship we have i know it's
head faults
but it hasn't been broken
and i think this is our up
an excellent opportunity to say let's
heal the wounds
of the past let's give congratulations
to
all parties i mean you look at the role
of te fiti in
our country's history
they were gandhi like
pacifists who brought a lot of
peace and inspiration when
they could have done the opposite
um and it's not if you
some of the um councillor safer referred
to
saying that it was
time i think that
that was a a critical
period in our history and
i was only elected for
uh six years on the auckland regional
council
and we had two representatives mrs
minhinik and another who
i can't remember now but they were two
ladies very respected well respected
and they felt that
it shouldn't be made of fuss off it
should just be a natural thing that they
want to be
represented on the table and paid
because often artists and activists
don't get paid
and they wanted to be the voice for
auckland
city with that time of 1.4 million
people and there was no objection
no controversy no fuss
and it passed through and
see it to framework for a
dynamic relationship not one that you're
dragged into but one that you
voluntarily
want to be part of um
so that's my brief i
i hope we can work our way through this
in the best manner possible i'm
not going into all the details that my
lunar colleague
um that
it has certainly an issue that
i feel proud to be part of
thank you thank you your worship
councillor abbott
yes i thank you for that um we're a
diverse range of people around this
table and in
various ages so my perspective from a
slightly older person
is a few notes that i made up and i
admit i vexed over this
because in my era we were brought up to
believe that everybody had potential for
development
and indeed success
but and it also said that in those days
democracy allowed anybody any culture
or even uh representation and
sadly i don't see those beliefs come to
fore anymore in
the pre-generation um i see
problems and uh what's the word i'm
looking for
my difficulties towards religion sexual
orientation
um all those sort of representations
cultures and i've seen prejudice to
racists
and individuals that i've known woman
lbgt
et cetera et cetera et cetera and
cultures
so i'm saying that uh why ivec says that
i believe that
all races and cultures should be
represented
and i'm going to support the original
nation because i think that like leslie
safer
this is a small step to the right action
now just a point of order here just
seeking clarification of where we are in
regards to talking about the amendment
which is purely about deferring
a decision-making process as opposed to
the actual substantive item which we've
yet to debate
thank you so here's the answer we've
just had three speakers speaking against
the amendment
i won't hear anybody else speaking
against the amendment
i will only hear from people who are
interested in speaking for thank you
good counting anyone in support of the
amendment
councillor kit thank you thank you mr
chairman um
councillor sober used the word brave
like making a decision like this is not
an act of bravery
i believe the timing of this
is rather hurried and
rushed to have everything in place
within a month the time frame is far
too short what i would like to see
happen
is that a group of people gathered here
today
the nominated people that there should
be a
a number of meetings with the mayor
and councillors i say meetings rather
than workshops or maybe some workshops
and to work out how it can work
and how we can make it work together so
that's why i would like it delayed
for the incoming council in 2022
and i congratulate councillor clark
on putting it forward and that's why i
signed it so we could have a discussion
about his
his ideas thank you thank you councillor
keith
speaking in support of the motion
creates a reset
those of you that are following the rule
book we can have three speakers one way
and three speakers the other side i
would like to put the motion
but okay so the motion
is uh that this paper be left
on the table without any decisions for
the upcoming council in october 2022
to consider and act upon that's the
amendment
can i call for a division on this you
can thank you
after we voted so all those
that support the amendment that's the
kicking for touch
for one for better term if you could
raise your right hand and say i
good eye all those who vote against
the amendment i
so division is yourself councillor
arnold and councillor keith voted
in support was there anybody who didn't
vote
no so the amendment is therefore lost so
we go back to the original
uh recommendations those are the
revised ones that set up there
and now we can start debate on that
is there anybody who counselor partner
look um our role as councillors is to
give effect
to the local government act and um
section 81 it's in our documents here
clearly states what we must do
and the key thing here is decision
making in the states establish and
maintain
processes to provide opportunities for
maori to contribute
to the decision making processes of the
local authority
and then consider ways in which it may
foster the development of marriage
capacity to contribute
to the decision-making processes of the
local authority
now our two standing committees provide
this opportunity because they have
delegated authority
and we are quite unique in new zealand
of having these two committees
and i think that giving effect to this
we are doing our job and i fully support
the six recommendations thank you
just a point of clarification of
clarification
michael the establishment of
of the the new roles
doesn't preclude our obligation
to consult with
the wider mighty community when there
are items of significance that come up
correct
councillors is there anyone just one
just one quick question here
yes through you mr chair um i notice
under the um
the local government act there is no
provision to have appointees on a full
council
how does it and i notice that you do say
it doesn't matter
but we have committees of full council
so is this a setting a precedent in law
or no so these committees are committees
set up
as committees under full council so
the resolution today is still going to
full council
so it is not it's quite entirely no
i'm talking about the appointees yeah so
the employees coming into the committees
are being appointed to the committee
and we make decisions for full council
at committee level that has been
delegated to
this committee so this committee has a
separate structure to full council
so for council can't have appointed
roles a committee can
it doesn't matter whether the committee
is a committee of everybody on council
or whether a committee is a committee
like a former structure where there may
have been
four or five councillors on that
committee
so this committee is a delegated
creature of
full council so by way of explanation
then
it would be possible that the next
council could change those delegations
yes thank you just so i can get it right
mr chair
in the past previous councils have had
three and sometimes four committees
so how would that
make the point appointees to a full
committee of council if you don't have a
full committee of council
what would happen then so mr morris the
question is what if we went back to full
committees
so if we went back to the full
committees essentially the roles can
continue on those four committees
this the decisions are still made in
those committees that then go up to full
council for voting on in the same manner
i can't tell you exactly how that would
work now because that will
actually be a decision for council in
november 2022 after the elections
but the principles that are in this
paper will carry through there is no
reason for it to be any different
it would just mean that there would be
smaller committees again
so again sorry mr chair it just it
depends on also what delegations full
council gives those
committees if the delegations were
similar to the delegations to these
current committees i.e the ability to
make decisions
then those voting rights will be
very powerful if the decision is to
not have delegations uh that
we go back to the old structure where
everything went through to full council
for decisions
uh then those voting rights are
diminished but they're not completely
irrelevant because the committee is
still recommending truthful council to
do something
and that information the manafena
reviews
the wider maori views are incorporated
into those decisions
as recommendations to council
councillor amundsen
thanks uh councillor ludlow i fully
support
these uh recommendations and i fully
support them
for a number of reasons um i think the
process that we went through
with engaging with the roonaka
during the consultation although
the questioning around the maori ward
was thorough i think it's really
important to note
that uh even though the question was
about having a maori ward
uh a lot of discussion did happen about
the pros and cons of that
and what are other options and so
manofenua's seats were talked about
quite often
and the the really strong impression
that i got from
everybody was that actually we just need
to do better
when it comes to engaging with maori and
having maori decision making as part of
our process
and so i think that's really important
to note sorry i've written all over my
page in all sorts of different
angles i think
there was the points raised by
councillor clark
around um the wider naitah conversation
um and the the leadership i guess of
naitahu but i think for us as people
in invercargill and bluff our question
needs to be asked to the
roonaka that are here and the strong
message from them
was that they want to be part of this
they want to be part of this decision
making and that really is our
should be our priority um there might be
changes coming with
various government changes in the future
we're under a local government review
um there's the heppup report that's
being talked about
and i think yep those things might
happen in the future or
and some of them hopefully should happen
in the future but actually we need to do
something now
we've had this obligation in the local
government act
since the local government act started
in 2002
um this council hasn't um you know put
enough effort into
uh addressing that obligation and doing
something about that obligation
and i don't think that saying that some
things might change in the next couple
of years or the next 10 years
or 20 years is a good enough reason to
not act
now
there was also some discussion or some
mention
about other opportunities that runanga
might have
not taken up with the mural forum i
think it needs to be
born in mind that the merrell form forum
is not a decision-making group
it's it's actually just an opportunity
to try and keep that regional approach
happening
um and i think it's uh you know this is
quite a different
opportunity or a place for maori to be
represented on our council
i do think that we need to make sure
that as part of this process that we
bear in mind
that engaging with wada maori including
mata waka
has to be part of our engagement
processes every single time
in the same way that we should be
engaging with people from the disabled
community
in the multicultural community in all of
those communities young people
elderly people and everything in between
you know we have an obligation to talk
to
literally everyone about the things that
we are wanting to do
as part of this council and so i think
that
we've made some really good progress
over the last wee while of doing better
at engaging
and i'm looking forward to seeing how we
continue to improve that over the next
coming years and i and i know that
that's what's
going to be happening here so i have
full confidence that that
is going to help
i guess address or alleviate those kind
of issues
and i think ultimately for me um the
reason for voting in favor of all these
recommendations
is actually not because it's my decision
but this is the decision for the lunaca
and the roonaka have said this is what
they want
and so i am voting in favor because this
is what
they want thank you council ahsoka
thank you mr chair i'm not going to
repeat what i said earlier in the
discussion on the amendment because i
think it is
very obvious that i support the
motions on the floor but i am going to
add something about the
local government act and our obligations
and i do think that people need to be
reminded that
clause 31 3 of the local government act
actually says that members of a
committee or subcommittee may
but need not be elected members of the
local authority
the local authority has the ability to
appoint
persons that have the skills attributes
or
knowledge that will assist the work of
the committee or subcommittee
i just want to reflect on the fact that
an import in suggesting the appointment
of the manufenua
appointees who will be chosen by the
roonaka
we are fulfilling the obligation
of having on our committee people with
the skills
attributes or knowledge in a very
important era
area for this council and for new
zealand as a whole
that will assist the work of our
committees
and for me that is another very sound
reason
why these why these recommendations
should be passed today
thank you councillor crackit oh thank
you councillor ludlow um
quite a bit of what i wanted to say has
already been said but
um i will make a couple of points that
have been
um we are governed by legislation
and it's not up for colonial new zealand
um i'm a delightful blend of both white
white presenting maori
and new zealand european um and as a
delightful blend this is
actually unlike my colleague councillor
abbott one of the easiest decisions i've
ever had to make
partnership is equal relationships need
to be equal
and to be given the money that they
deserve the status quo
opting for the status quo or to even
leave this on the table
acknowledges neither of those nor does
it acknowledge our previously stated
legislative requirements
the point has been made that um we if we
appoint these um
seats that it doesn't shirk our
obligation to the other sixty percent of
south and ewe that aren't
manifest um
i know this council will probably get
sick of me saying this but
whenever i make any decisions for me it
is about making more capa decisions
and the decisions are not for myself or
for ourselves but for the next
generation of invercargill
so i think that with that in mind i'll
absolutely
resoundingly 100 percent be voting
for establishing these seats on our
council
thank you councillor rabbit i don't know
that's all right it's uh just i'm going
around the table now on on the
substantive motion because around we
hear from your counselor clark
yeah thank you jim um just a couple of
things um
and comment to um the previous
oh sorry in response to alex's comments
about partnership being equal giving
manafenoua two seats on a committee of
15 people
is not equality and some would argue
it's tokenism
so i'm not opposed to rangatiratanga i
see that as
a way forward but ewe will reflect
and i've heard this many times that
they've had appointments and
consultation positions on many many
council
committees both government and and and
other committees as well
and those committees have delivered
little or nothing while our progress to
the well-being of
ewe um i've spent most of my life in
uh trying to find ways to enhance the
well-being of maori families and
different roles i've had
so uh i'm still opposed to that
thank you thank you councillor skelt
thank you to you chair um thank you
michael for the was always comprehensive
report and also to nobby
for your thought-provoking paper um gave
us a bit of objectivity around the whole
process look um to me it's it's quite
simple um
it's simply the right thing to do we
don't have to be brave we don't have to
be
it's just the right thing to do and it
is time
it's the right thing to do michael just
a couple of points for me
in the sense of your paper um renaka
have indicated they are interested in
exploring
that's a little bit open for me they are
interested in exploring so
my only nervousness around that point
is have we completely fulfilled our as a
council
our consultation obligations with the
roonaka to make sure that we've got
exactly what they do
want because we'd be very grave and
from our perspective we haven't explored
that completely and i know from your own
words
you did mention um around that
consultation so that would be my own
only to make sure that we have a
complete picture
exactly what they are acquiring or
asking for
um because we can't afford to make a
mistake it's that the time is right
michael certainly i'm very comfortable
that we are representing
um what manifesto have told us
uh and i believe anyone who was present
at the
long term plan engagement with uh
will have heard that message
loud and clear thank you you're right
there's just somebody on the grassy
knoll
you worship do you want a chance to
speak on the substantive motion
i just um it's i must say i'm
impressed that we've got such a
liberal-minded counsel
and it's surprising and heartening to
see that we're prepared to
face change thank you sir counselor kit
um on the substantive motion you only
asked a question so if there's an
opportunity for you to speak if you wish
uh could i ask another question please
certainly
uh michael um
these uh two appointees
do they have to be maori the appointees
from this group
or can they be from some other race
uh the manafino and the nominate whoever
they
feel would be the most appropriate
person so therefore we
could have an irishman and a dutchman if
manifenua believed that they were the
most appropriate people to represent
them on these committees
yes i believe without achieving what
what they are representing
and that is what this is these roles are
intended to do
thank you councillor lash yeah um
through you the chair um
i was very nervous about coming to the
meeting today um about this discussion
and the way it was going to go but
incredibly heartened by the
well thought out comments of people
towards this um
like your worship i was staggered by
matariki at the queen's park i thought
gee this is going to be interesting
sensational with so much involvement for
me we had so much involvement for the
community
i wasn't expecting arch but people were
loving it and maybe not so much me
because it's lights and trees but the
children were in
awe of it and you know i just think this
is
it's exciting for me as a new counselor
to be involved with something that seems
to be so
um such a positive thing to do under the
local government act under the treaty
and for the community um
look i think that's um
it's good for invercargill to get good
news stories around things like this
there have been stories to do with
race have come out of invercar that have
gone nationwide that have put us
in a bad light in some ways hopefully
this is a
a uh story that will will go positive
around the country there's been certain
councils that have struggled with this
and it has not gone well for the
reputation of those cities i think with
challenges that new zealand has and the
world has
with climate change and the environment
and tourism
to have this representation is
incredibly valid i also think too as we
look towards the establishment of a
museum
um 50 million dollars 60 million dollars
and i think too when we look at the
stories that we have to tell
in bluff and invercargill that so many
of those involve
naitahu and i think that to have the
involvement
of representatives of the ewe on the
committee is a great thing so i think
i'll certainly vote in favor of this i
think it's a
really really positive thing and yeah
i'm like your worship i'm heartened by
the opinions and the sense of process as
well the council's come up with this
um this proposal and yeah hopefully
it'll pass too so thank you
thank you as the mover of the motion
i'll
give the final word um i'm really
heartened to see that we have grown to a
point where we want to
continue to grow what we're
looking to do is to seek to give voice
and to get
understanding um
and understanding from manafenoua of of
what it is that they want you can have
somebody who's got maori lineage and
there are a couple of us who sit at the
table but we're not the appointed voices
not even close
but i come from a generation where um
sadly our engagement with maori culture
was
some flex weaving poi stick songs
real 1970s
shame goes beyond that
i then went through a really interesting
period of learning when i was
uh taking a unit around tatiati when i
was working for the southern institute
of technology and i watched the the
reactions of
of some of the students to just having
to learn
about the treaty and and there was in
some instances
resistance and and i understand that
because resistance comes from a place of
fear
or just just a lack of understanding um
and and i would talk to the students and
help tell them that i didn't care about
their politics
i simply wanted to teach them a timeline
so that they understood what led to the
signing of the treaty why there are two
different versions and why there is
disagreement
often with i think one exception across
five years
the response from those who were
reluctant
was astounding i had no idea
was the most frequent reaction
so let's have an idea and it sounds like
you know we are a council that is that
is ready to start to listen we talk
about a a treaty partnership but
for a true partnership you'd actually
need more seats
an equal number but here's the start and
here's the now
there may be change coming the one
constant that we know will happen in
local government
is that there's going to be change it's
going to be change around the local
government there's going to be change
around the rma there's going to be
change around three waters
there's going to be change around the
way that we want to integrate and
understand what it is
the people of uh
manafinoa locally want
so it's with a bit of pride
that i will um put the motion
all those in favor please say aye aye
against would you like your vote
recorded councillor clare thank you
thank you any other votes against to be
recorded
if not thank you councillors and thank
you for the manner in which you've
engaged
speaking of engagement that brings us to
the uh the representation
review and my thanks to the members of
the representation review committee who
have been along here through this
afternoon i know this one has had to pop
away already
um but michael do you want to take us
through that paper
aditi had to run thank you thank you mr
chair i was trying to work out who had
escaped um well she i don't know she
hasn't got out of the building but
something it was as i'm sure you're all
aware every six years we have the joyful
task of undertaking a representation
review
uh it is our turn for next early the
elections next year
um and so we have been undertaking
up-to-date our pre-engagement with our
community panel which uh mr chair has
already
commented on so at this stage i will
publicly
acknowledge the community panel uh
chaired by councilwoman
and made up of aditiraj anna ford
david pottinger michaels garrett and
evelyn cook
i wish to thank them all for their very
hard work and their comprehensive report
they have provided
and as part of my presentation i am
aware that some of the community panel
wish to speak to you
so i would like with your leave mr chair
to invite them to do so now
absolutely
evelyn welcome along and thank you for
your mahi through this project
i'm not so much that i wish to speak to
you necessarily but
that i was here to support the report
and answer any questions that may come
out of that
regarding manufa
and consultation with mata waka
thank you are there any questions around
those two issues
what's your level of comfort
with the discussions yes
depends on the question um i'm fairly
open to
um i think the process that we undertook
was robust
the discussions that we had with amongst
ourselves was likewise robust
and more than happy to support
the reporters that's presented to you
and to defend anything that
may be asked particularly pertaining to
my
input but the the
way that the report speaks about
the matters that were before us
thank you evelyn david welcome
councillor ludlow your honor
fellow councillors bro
i'm here to talk about what wasn't said
in the report
because uh in the last wee while
discussing with people
about the actions of the council has
been an interesting experience
and while we made recommendations in the
report
which you you will have seen about the
numbers of councillors the
the um committees and the
awards and all that there was a great
deal of other information that was made
clear to me
when i went to talk about you people
and it was made i had people ringing me
up at home they had seen my name
on a list and i'm still possession of a
landline so available in the phone book
and it's those those issues i might
if i can there are three issues
one is knowledge many of the people in
invercargill do not know
what the council does you get confused
with the ilt and therefore come in for a
bit of abuse
you um they don't understand and hence
the comment i think in the report
about rates what are rates what do they
do who are they set
what happens all my rates have gone up
in the area that i live
next to kennington some of them were
quite upset
there's a whole lot of issues there so
that's number one they don't know what
you do
number two 25
of the available people voted most of
them voted for
councillor lush i might point out not
for me
i am i am however a great supporter of
the council i mean
i i tried to join you so i can't say any
other thing
other anything else but 25
and in 2019 it was just over 50
that is a worry people are not voting
it's not just
an invercargill it's a national trend
but
local bodies are not getting the support
you sit here and you make decisions for
the entire city
having only been put here by half of it
or in
marcus's case one quarter of it
and thirdly was diversity
and this was an issue that we came
across
and there are lots of we've talked about
diversity as i talked about diversity in
the people and the
the different groups that make up
invercargill and i look round the
council
and somebody described and i do not do
not take this personally anybody here
but somebody described me as you lot as
being
male pale and style
and i defended that because i too
fit into that category and i wish to
stand but this
is an issue it's not part of our review
our review says we like 12 of you
our review says we like being
councillors at large that all of you
represent invercargill city
and as far as community boards go we
spare a thought for the people of
odatara i work with a number of them and
they were
they had their issues but you'll see
that in the report
but it's the other three things people
don't know what you do
people don't want to be part of the
process
and people don't see that you fully
represent them because of who you are
now they they don't know you as well as
i do i know many of you and
you're thoroughly good people but the
i see that the council has
an issue in front of it it's got stones
in its shoe
it's got um issues it's
facing under the changing environment
which we've just heard about
but also we you've got the need the
council's got the need
to be seen as relevant and
part of the changes that invercargill's
going through because nobody's yet
talked about uh
ty and the effects that's going to have
down the track
and um the fact that the very boom is
slowing and there's a whole lot of other
issues there that are going to affect
invercargill and
i think the future of the council
lies in council's hands and maybe at
some stage
if you go after this meeting and it's
been a very momentous meeting i might
point out
but you need to think about how we can
address
some of these issues and some of this so
the people of invercargill
can be assured that you're sitting here
making the best decisions
for them in the now and in the future
thank you thanks david councillor
emerson you have been a councillor
representative and chaired this process
for the second time
so no stranger to it can i hand to you
sure thank you uh yes
i would just like to extend my thanks to
the community
panel as well they've been amazing to
work with
and there has been lots of robust
discussion about the different areas
which we are supposed to address as part
of the representation review which is
the
at large versus ward system the number
of councillors
and the community board and i think it's
fair to say that the
otata community board discussion or
potential for one was
probably the most debated
uh issue that we had alongside the
suggestion of reducing the number of
councillors so
it did take a wee bit of discussion to
to come to a conclusion there but
as you'll see from our report
we did come to a conclusion and i guess
just to follow on from what david was
saying
around the issues that he found they
were certainly echoed by a lot of people
in the community
so i'm really pleased to see that there
is a recommendation here that
asks the chief executive to look at
options for addressing some of those
things
um or hopefully all of them actually
because i think
they'll go a long way to helping raise
uh i guess uh awareness about council
you know and i find too you know people
make all sorts of assumptions about
councillors and council uh you know
people expect that i have an office here
in this building and i'm like no
they're like oh but don't you work there
and it's like no
you know and and all of those kinds of
things all of those little things that
people
sort of don't realize alongside the big
things and i think
you know one of the things that was
raised was that somebody
was working with somebody who was buying
a house and they didn't even know what
rates were
uh you know so things like that i think
uh you know
that's significant issues for councils
not just ours but i think councils
across the country
to try and work out how do we get people
to have a better understanding about
uh what council does and and why it does
it
and by association the value that they
need to place
on getting involved in voting at one
level
but i think engaging in the different uh
sort of engagement processes
on another level as well uh so yes so
i'm
am i allowed to move was leading to that
yes well
with that i would really like to uh move
these recommendations thank you
thank you thank you um and just to prove
that i did read your report
um i noticed that stv is one of those
things you wanted to get back up onto
the table for discussion as well
can i ask david and evelyn how that
discussion went because we know how it
went
at our table but um
we were a bit puzzled as to why you
didn't adopt it
um most of us thought that stv or some
form
of alternative um
weighted represent um voting process
would
result in a more
varied look around the council
um given that many people who vote under
that system for example
mnp has proved that people actually will
vote
quite strategically that if that was
available
a form of
mixed voting would result in a possibly
quite different looking council
in the future and whether that was the
reason that people were scared of it
but however we we do think it should be
given a a much more thoughtful
um less
less time pressured consideration
that people educate themselves on what
that might mean
in terms of what future councils may
look like
thank you david evelyn just hit on the
education people didn't know what his tv
was
it was not part of our brief and i
talked to a number of people about it
and explained it to them but they did
not know
they do not know the options
um you know my wife is a teacher
and she teaches social studies and the
whole nature of this
local body governance process is not
fully understood
and if you do not learn about it in
school then you learn about it in life
or various other places that some of you
might frequent
that um and you get the wrong idea
so people had enough
dealing with the concept that if there
are only eight of you around this table
why wouldn't it cost less
right i said it would cost the same well
why not have more
or as many people sincerely put it
get rid of the whole
lot of them it was but the comments that
was reflected in the report
yeah the report reflected the polite
version of the comments
because it came at an interesting time
mr chair
because there was a great deal in the
media
about you people and people confuse
what you're trying to do and
i think education indication about stv
for education about
how the lack of government role works
the understanding
that there's a lot of work to be done
here
and that way maybe we could reverse the
slowing trend of um
what's happening thank you
councillor look i just wanted to comment
on the stb
um topic because
working with the three waters thing i've
i've i've been a lot in contact with a
lot of
senior counsellors throughout south
island and one thing we have touched on
was these tv and they were amazed that
we weren't stv
and they they they generously gave
their opinion on why
on why it works so well and it was an
eye opener to me too
and i think the education i think this
council should be fully educated on its
on on the way it works and it should be
considered
council ashoka thank you mr chair as one
of those who supported stv as an option
i totally agree with that
i also just for the panel's information
because you may not have
realized it but we have as a council
given our delegates to the local
government conference
the ability to vote in favour of civics
education
now that's a nationwide issue and it may
or may not carry through
the conference but there is
i certainly believe there is more that
we could do even locally
in the way of education workshops
um the sort of thing that the second
part of the recommendation
suggests that the ceo comes back with
some
recommendations on so i think there is a
great deal more we can do but just to
reassure
you as panel members that we have as a
council supported
further education as a formal
part of the school system which which
will help
with the future generation my step
grandchildren
counselor crickets child child
and hopefully will educate some of the
parents of those who will
get that education but there are
certainly more i believe we can do
to increase that knowledge and to
increase
people's um belief that there is a
reason to vote
in local government elections
councillor clark just one reflection on
what on what evelyn
commented on about stv um if you look at
the recent results in
in the last election in dunedin and
wellington you see some significant
changes
certainly in the wellington landscape
gone away from the uh
male parel and style um to a majority or
female
significant amount of um marion pacifica
representation and the age is probably
hard so it's a significant impact in
williamson and that's
partly and due to a different voting
system and
insane for dunedin as well thank you
dave i can't really get away with a
couple of comments you've seen we've got
the media behind me so i'm gonna have a
crack
um no i'm not really but knowing what we
do
i've just looked back in the sense of
what our team have done from a comms
perspective
and the last ltp and the communication
that goes out in my opinion
and i'm defending the team here and my
opinion it's been outstanding
the ltp and the communication the amount
of material
that went out right through every piece
of social media
every piece of streaming that we did was
phenomenal
and i compare that with many other
councils so can't get away with that
also i have concerns when folk come in
and say
many people it's a very small
small side sweep that you've taken the
group have taken of people in our
community
when you get when feedback like that
comes what i'm more concerned about
when we're more interested on a positive
note uh
is that our young people's voice could
you give us a bit of a
very quick reflection on where that was
in in the consultation because that
would be really
worthwhile
i think it would be fair to say that i'm
at the more mature end of the spectrum
and that um i probably speak to people
who are more
um politically aware perhaps then
and and actively involved politically
in ewe politics or or matawaka politics
then
then is the normal run of people because
i meet them at tangi and i meet the
midway and
i meet them on the mirai on the street
sometimes occasionally in a coffee house
but
um young people
are as varied as we are in the terms of
their engagement so the young people
that i know are also very politically
ewe politics engaged so their opinion
tends to be
more of the
reflective of the fact that they are
more knowledgeable they perhaps are
a little bit educated um
you know most of a couple of our young
ones were sitting behind us before
they've they're they've got degrees or
varying interests
um in terms of their work life that
brings them into context
so i take your point that the people
with whom we consulted cannot ever be
fully representative but then
nothing that you do is ever fully
representative
but i would say that the young people
with whom i engaged in this matter
were about time what's taken you so long
um you know um we're glad we're not
going to have to wait until we're as old
as you
um i think that might have been my son
um
uh but you know that that
this has taken us 181 years
the conversation that we're having now
that that you had earlier
that's taken 181 years that is
not really a rush to the finish line um
so can i just sort of say that whatever
we got from the people with whom we
spoke
was colored by who we are and who we
know
and where we could access people because
we didn't have the luxury of the public
meetings
although i think david sacrificed
himself and went to more than me
um but you know we we can only reflect
just as you can the people with whom you
converse and
um and the people who volunteer their
opinions upon you thank you
um yeah you're right when i say many
i mean but i use statistics
lies damn lies and statistics 25
voted in the by-election that's how i
mean many
75 and the people i spoke to
weren't weren't politically motivated
they were the
apprentices and the junior operators
that i work the people who are trying to
buy a house the people who are trying to
get their life together the guy who's
had more rouse than with his partner
than he cares to
care about and i asked about the council
and i asked about the roles and asked
about those
um their need is for the
the basic knowledge i i'm just worried
nigel that the um
the the public of invercargill the
community of invercargill
needs to see what's happening here
what they're seeing in the papers all
they're at the thompson report and all
that other stuff
that was out there in the playing field
when we were doing this
they need to see this is all relevant as
it is important
to the city and that's why
i did what what you're doing
evelyn would agree they said keep 12
people keep it the way it is
just maybe different people
maybe understand what's going on
that's all it's it's it's not
it's not difficult it's not changed it's
not throw the baby out with the bath
water
so let's let's work with that and when i
say many well
that's i guess i'm just using figures
that i've gone through and
researched i mean the um
51 of invercargill is
female the voting population
we know that there's uh 85 percent
pakeha 17
the numbers don't add up because some
people are multicultural
but we need to be addressing this these
issues because those are the ones that
were raised with us
but they weren't part of our
representation review
thank you councillor clark just one one
quick quick bit of good news
um based on what nigel and david have
both said
the range for participation in local
body elections ranges across the country
from 35
to 60 and i can tell you we're 60.
um yeah excluding the by-election
oh forgetting the by-election yeah well
marcus marcus
put away too many votes here
yes we do better than the rest of new
zealand but
even on the basis of that the number
isn't growing
and as you say uh you know it's it's
through a lack of understanding
uh the one thing you know is that people
don't care about the council until their
card disappears into a pothole
which i think was the last time i put
through a request for service
uh somebody's gonna collect the rubbish
is that when you're flush
everything goes apart from that every
quarter when you pay your rights you'll
have a grumble
but for those of us that work within it
we understand it's
it's a great deal more but we certainly
thank you for your mahi over the weeks
it's been moved by councillor amundsen
and uh
was seconded by councillor cricket
i'll put the motion all in favor aye
against carried thank you
it's all the good source today uh which
brings us to the active communities
funding
rihanna and uh also welcome along
brandon mcdermott from sports south and
you want to come and have a
seat up there brenda
sorry from active southland that's my
bad
thanks rhiannon this this follows a lead
that that came from council a while ago
so
we're now at the mechanics point i guess
one way of summing it up
thank you chair kia ora councillors so
um
yes you'll recall that this was raised
during the review
of funding that took place in august
last year so since then we've been
engaging with now active southland as
well as sport new zealand
around the options around this and so
this paper presents those
options to you for your consideration
our recommendation is the act of
southland is
best place to really drive improved
community outcomes
from the funding um and
that the the most efficient manner to
enable that to happen is to wind up the
trust
and pass the funding across to active
south and for administration going
forward
and so yeah happy to take any questions
i guess by way of comment i was
on council back when we were getting
funding from
the then hillary commission to
disseminate
and the amount of money that people were
drawing on was far lighter than the
amount of money
that we were getting and so this fund
accumulated and i don't think it was
ever the intention of
council that the fund should accumulate
to the point where it becomes
self-seeding um i also noted that
through lockdown last year as a lot of
sporting organizations
uh struggled to survive
that there was a fund administered by
the
then sport southland now act of
southland
brendan could you explain how
going through that process uh
impacted on on what it is you do bearing
in mind that normally you were on the
end of applying for funding killer
councillors
yes i i guess from a funding perspective
um
then sports southland um has been
distributing funds through kiwi sports
for the last
kiwi sport funding for the last 10 years
so around about 2 million
over the last 10 years and then through
sport new zealand and money that come
through the government with the
opportunity to distribute money through
the
community resilience fund to spawning um
and recreation
organizations last year to enable them
to help them through that short any
shortfall they may have
through um through the post covered
time so um it was two funds
i think the first one were restricted to
about 350 odd thousand dollars which we
distributed
uh to regional sports organizations and
clubs and then secondly uh a second fund
which we oversubscribed and then sport
new zealand gave us extra money because
of the
over subscription uh and it was about
the 650 so we had about a million
dollars we distributed it out to around
about 200 different organizations to
support them
uh post covert uh to keep them running
um
and to my knowledge i don't think we've
had any clubs fold
organizations fold post covert in terms
of sporting and recreation
organizations which is great councillor
soper
your name appears on on some of the
documentation as a member of the trust
what's your level of comfort with what's
proposed
thank you mr chair um i'm actually very
happy to move these recommendations
um it's been my view for a while that
it's really been a historic accident
that this council and other councils
ever ended up with the hillary's
commission money in the first place
and because we did a set of criteria
were drawn up those criteria are now
somewhat dated some parts of them are
very good some parts of them are very
dated
we have as a an active communities
committee
as a subcommittee of the trust made some
adjustment
to those criteria but they would need
quite a bit of further adjustment if we
were to
not pass these recommendations today it
seems to me that with
a places and spaces strategy in place
all the discussion that has gone into
that
um the the role that we know that
um sports south and now active southland
plays
in the community the fact that they are
the
um in my mind the more appropriate
place for this funding to reside
and we can obviously as council give
some some
guidelines as is said in the report
about the use of of the money that would
be in the spirit of the original hillary
commission
devolution but it certainly seems to me
that
this would be a very good move it is a
reasonably expensive
matter for council to continue to
administer this
trust it's a very unusual trust
it's not part of our core business it
wouldn't exist if the hillary commission
hadn't
devolved the funding they did at a
certain historic point
when i wrote to sport new zealand
initially to ask about the fund i would
have to say there was
perhaps some surprise from sport new
zealand that
the fun still existed in this council's
hands
and that it had grown to quite the level
it had it would seem other councils
who had the same historic accident
did not necessarily go down
airpath in quite the same way so it
seems to me
that it is a good time
to put the funding in responsible
active communities hands
and with an organisation that council
can have a high level of trust as the
appropriate body to administer the
funding
[Music]
i think it's a fantastic idea i think
there's too much inconsistency with
council doing it
the change of each term has new people i
think it enables
a strategic approach a cohesive approach
that it gets administered
like this and i'm all a favor and let's
go for it thank you uh
jeff we turn the heating off after five
o'clock it tends to hurry us along
um i i think right that's um the
point that councillor soper made around
conditions
as long as it's delivered with the same
intent with which the hillary commission
granted the money in the first instance
sports
southland now active south and has the
networking within the community to to
understand where needs are
are best met it's nothing to do with
electricity
no councillor scout i just want to echo
your comments councillor sopers and
councillor pottinger's um
active south and do an outstanding job
in the wider community um
and i was lucky enough to be at the
launch the other day and
did you speak at it i did speak at it
actually but to be fair
um more importantly the community reach
that the organisation is making
is very significant and so
congratulations brendan to the team uh
i think even the naming has encompassed
a whole lot more with active
south and so um it's the right place
again it's the right thing to do
i believe so well
thank you any further questions or
comments
counselor evanson i'm just trying to
find
um would the expectation be that
the same amount of funding is allocated
each year to be distributed
uh so that the principal remains and it
can be
a no
because it never should have been and
and i guess
if if in disseminating the funding act
of south and
find projects that are that are worthy i
mean when the money's gone it's gone
interest rates and it wasn't ever
supposed to be something that generated
revenue from interest right and that was
from
peter miss kim in the denver i think he
was in charge of sport new zealand he
may still well be
right no if i can back that up
counsellor
um that's that's exactly the
position the it's another part of the
historic accident
of the fund evolution and the way
historically
this council decided to deal with the
funding it's
not necessarily the best way
for this funding to deliver active
communities results
in 2021
thank you know the comments if not to
put the motion then all in favor aye aye
aye against carried thank you
thank you thank you brendan
rhiannon you get to stay in the hot seat
uh
just really an update on the saving
grace project because i know that there
was an expectation through the ltp that
we would report back to the july meeting
of ppp yes so this report is very much
um just to provide an update on where
those conversations
are at i will just note one change that
i just need to make to report this says
that we will bring a report back in
august
but i'm having received information um
from the ic2 trust that they're waiting
on some additional information
that will mean we couldn't report back
in august it's actually going to be
september so i just
beg patience on that and we've had some
initial
conversations as the report outlines um
and they've
indicated that they understand the
conditions
around the funding obviously not to be
for purchase of the building
initial conversations are around
refurbishment
and so we'll shape up
a further report come back to this
committee in september
thank you councillor second that mr
chair
questions or comments counselor clay on
page 71 rihanna um
you've got there written in italics the
council allocate a hundred thousand four
officers to work alongside
and for me that's a little bit
miscellaneous i thought we allocated
100 000 towards the project with the
potential for
two more lots in subsequent years and
that the way that reads it sort of
implies that we're giving a hundred
thousand
officers for their work to work
alongside the trust
so just seeking some clarification on
that
councillor hammondson so um i think
that's probably just one of those things
that uh
ended up being part of the impression of
the
recommendation when we were pinning it
on the move
so what it does mean is that the hundred
thousand dollars is for the saving grace
project uh but first the officers are
going to work alongside just
to make sure that that money is
allocated but it was we did only agree
in that ltp
to do the one-off allocation we didn't
agree to do subsequent demonstrations
okay that's fine thank you thank you
further questions or comments if not
it's been
moved and seconded i'll put the motion
all in favor
against can we note my abstention
i have an interest not a conflict easier
if i just sit off to the side
and that brings us to the activity
report who wants the
the joyous task of speaking to these
magnificent figures from
the likes of the library i can
mr chair um willingly he steps forward
willingly step forward
um first i might just if i may
counselors introduce you to treaty hurst
who is the gm for customer environment
this is treaty's
day number two and she'll be taking this
seat from me
in the next meeting which i'm grateful
for um
so i'm happy to take the report as read
and we'll answer any questions you might
have
so i'm just going to go back to the
library because it was such a
significant jump
was there any ain't a great thing to say
but was there anything they were able to
put that down to
uh to a degree part of the issue will
have been
um called this time or in may last year
the library was just popping out of
covert
and so that's why the numbers and the
percentage variation look
quite significant but but what we have
seen
in terms of the library service is
across the board that their programs
are in the range of services they do
offer including the lending of
both books lego dvds and the like
has increased and so we are seeing more
people engage
and also seeing their engagement is
shifting
to more remote terms of access rather
than just coming into the building to
grab a book
they are engaging through other means
too
thank you i also know with venues and
events services report that there was
such a thing as a silent disco
um it was actually oh i see
a point about uh minerva in the update
as well which i note that um
councillor crackit shared around two so
that's been good
councillor scout thank you through
youtube being a white
pale stale and now very grumpy
because it's very cold in here um i
wonder if you could help me with some
gibbling um just a couple of things um
the anderson house trust
and the workshops could we flesh out a
bit more just in the sense of
time frames and how we're rolling with
that project
uh so the second
that the manager from the venues and
events team richard mccoy
has been working with a subgroup of the
trust
that have run through a range of
discussions on both
the potential future use and that has
included bringing in
um event and wedding specialists
catering specialists to provide
um advice to the trust on on the
realities of
operating that venue in a range of
guises
and from richard's work and with the
trust
they are now looking at wrapping up
their advice and that should be with us
it is staff it should be with us within
the next month
and then we'll be bringing that back as
advice to
council once we're clear and once we
know what the trust's views are
and that they've had an input into that
shape of report
and just from an operational point of
view steve just the
scaffold we're on time we're on target
with anderson's house in the sense of
when we might be weatherproofing
uh that's stretching my memory about
councillor scout
in terms of the capital program
it's a question if i can i will pass on
to erin
and we can come back with a specific
answer on
how that's tracking okay thank you and
just one other thing just three
venues events just the the number of
events coming through all the
shows and things coming through would it
be or was is there any indicator in the
sense of numbers attending
how are we tracking in the sense of um
through the covert
and the after cover numbers going to the
actual events is quite interesting
and i know we can't from a promoter's
point of view
um be too detailed around that for
confidentiality but it'll be interesting
to know just
in a reporting process are we getting
significant numbers to those
or are we is there sorry is there a sign
that we may be trickling off to
attendance to those sort of events when
i look at
the range of activity i noticed the
article the other day re-lammers
and just there's a real pressure point
there on numbers so
is there an indicator just or a snapshot
what sort of numbers we are getting
look i think the general indication from
the management team
is that within the civic and scottish
that we are getting
better engagement from the community and
that includes
um tickets but that also reflects
um we're actually getting a different
behavior but from the promoters you know
they are
tending to book book more and they're
and probably still in a bit of catch-up
mode post covert
so we it's hard to point a finger to one
thing or another but we do know that
promoters are more active at the moment
and so they are bringing more shows than
we would have normally
got pre-covered richard has noted in the
report too
around the ticketing behavior
and purchasing behavior of people as
they are waiting longer
and that's leaving it up to other
factors as well so
okay i can ask richard to see if he can
include more information than his next
report around that
well that was just interesting and it's
in that very point you made around that
risk factor for promoters and coming and
and obviously numbers the numbers game
and and from a ticketing perspective
revenue stream off ticketing for
for us from a council perspective so
it's just interesting to know
where the market's sitting the youth
market's sitting and what is big what
what folk
so what sort of events are now
attracting our people to go to
and whether collectively as a community
we can be even stronger in driving that
and getting more of that type of thing
into the city as a bigger picture type
thing so
but thank you that's that's good
information someone like to move the
reports received
councillor rabbit seconded
councillor amundsen there are no further
questions or comments
sorry just a quick one for steve um
i wasn't clearing what you responded
back to nigel on but um
my understanding was with the anderson's
house we were going to have two phases
one was to
do the earthquake prime work and seal
the building
and then the second phase was to
identify what potential uses there would
be and that might
that might run us into things like
toilets and kitchens and
access ramps and what have you so we i
didn't
quite get what you were saying to him in
relation to are we going down the track
of resolving the earthquake prime stuff
and ceiling building so um
thank you counselor um so the the
capital program
is on track to be completed and i think
that is on track to be completed by may
of next year and that includes the
strengthening
and weather tightness work concurrently
richard is working with the trust to
determine once that
piece of work is finished what can the
facility be used
initially and then that will then drive
that ongoing
potential future use and just as a side
question in relation to what uh
council orlando wrote are you counting
them in and out of the library or just
in
that's a very good question uh we've got
counters on the door
yeah very good yeah no that's fine thank
you
i've got a double click on them yeah
yeah of course
councillor partner i'd like to move
we're going to public excluded
i haven't put the motion yet
so i'm glad to move that the report is
received
counselor scout counseling
there being no further business and open
i'll move that we go into public
acceptable counselor
passenger is moving that would go into
public excluded with the exception of mr
grant mr mckenzie
as the external appointees and relevant
staff for the reasons
as outlined secondary
systems i'll put that all in favor aye
carried